[Music]
today is a day that happens once a
century did you know that yeah it is
twelve twelve twelve yeah that's right
twelve twelve twelve it's not only the
date it's also the results from the
Kardashian sisters IQ test
[Applause]
[Music]
know why I'm dancin president george w
bush gonna be a grandfather for the
first time yeah bullshitter doesn't care
whether it's a boy or a girl as long as
he doesn't have to share his Legos with
it it's going on New Jersey in New
Jersey Democrats fear that Republican
Governor Chris Christie will be
impossible to beat yes it's unclear if
they're talking about the 2013 governors
race or the Coney Island hot dog eating
contest good news for you Andy
what's that Conan if you could bottle
this chemistry you'd have a deadly serum
no last night the the Spice Girls
musical debuted in London so it turns
out the Mayans were off by just a few
weeks
[Applause]
I'm sporty that's mine
your baby spice whatever you want me to
be okay thank you
speaking of the Mayan apocalypse a top
Vatican scientist has officially
announced that despite the Mayan
calendar the world will not end on
December 21st
yeah the Vatican scientists that went
back to his regular work proving
tornadoes are caused by gay people
[Applause]
according to the Census Bureau white
people will not be the majority in the
United States by the year 2043 yeah yeah
so this is even more bad news for the
National Hockey League I'm sick
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
scientists say what was that in a piece
of my lung just come out there it's pity
it's just pity yeah pity laughter yeah
scientists scientists say that they have
found evidence of cheese being made
seven thousand five hundred years ago
that amazing seven thousand five hundred
indeed a seven-eleven nacho bar
[Applause]
you get a little chip that guy right
right sure
that's all scientists have chips
got mentioned this fashion designers
have come out with a new kind of
leggings for men called meggings yeah
they're yeah they're expected to be most
popular with a group of men called moosh
bags
[Applause]
[Music]